aquí tenemos una captura de pantalla de
nuestro vídeo anterior y vamos a
utilizar esta captura para redibujar
estas dos moléculas así que empecemos
con el de la izquierda aquí en el centro
tenemos un átomo de carbono entonces
vamos a poner nuestro átomo de carbono
que está unido hacia arriba con un átomo
de hidrógeno verdad mientras que hacia
la derecha hacia la derecha está unido
con un átomo de cloro verdad y todas
estas estas estos tres átomos se
encuentran digamos sobre el mismo plano
sobre la misma hoja de papel hacia
nosotros se está dirigiendo un átomo de
bromo así que esto se representa digamos
usando una cuña y eso nos está diciendo
que el bromo está saltando hacia
nosotros a partir de la digamos del
plano de la hoja de papel donde se
encontraban los otros tres mientras que
acá atrás tenemos un átomo de flúor
verdad entonces lo representamos con una
línea punteada y ahí tenemos una
representación de nuestra molécula
verdad
por otro lado del lado derecho tenemos
una molécula digamos que sabemos que es
distinta verdad y que de hecho es la
imagen espejo de la que teníamos en la
izquierda y como no las podemos
superponer digamos no podemos superponer
la molécula de la derecha con la de la
izquierda entonces realmente es una
molécula distinta así que vamos a tratar
de dibujarlo nuevamente en el centro
tenemos nuestro átomo de carbono ahí
está nuestro auto mode carbono que está
unido hacia arriba con el átomo de
hidrógeno y hacia la izquierda con el
átomo de cloro verdad ahora se encuentra
hacia la izquierda el átomo de cloro
mientras que hacia la derecha pero hacia
el frente
tenemos el átomo de bromo que difiere
del caso anterior porque teníamos que
dar hacia la izquierda mientras que acá
está hacia la derecha y finalmente hacia
atrás hacia atrás pero hacia la derecha
tenemos nuestro átomo de flúor ahora
vamos a utilizar estas imágenes para
hablar de tres definiciones
aquí tenemos la primera de ellas nos
dice que son los estéreo y son menos
verdad y esencialmente son isómeros y
sabemos que un isómero se puede
descomponer digamos en su parte hizo que
significa mismo y menos que son partes
son las mismas partes verdad solo que
estas mismas partes difieren en su
arreglo tridimensional ok en el arreglo
en tres dimensiones de sus átomos así
que podremos pensar que la palabra y
somero nuevamente bueno como habíamos
dicho isómeros significa mismas partes
estas dos moléculas que son diferentes
están compuestas de las mismas partes
verdad cada una de estas moléculas
contiene un carbono
contiene un hidrógeno un flúor y un
bromo ok de hecho también contiene un
cloro verdad entonces tienen las mismas
partes y en términos de qué tipo de
isómeros son hemos hablado también de
los isómeros estructura estructurales
perdonen en ocasiones anteriores verdad
son isómeros estructurales o
constitucionales y no podemos
clasificarlos éstos como y son menos
estructurales déjenme
dibujar su estructura de puntos digamos
aquí tenemos el carbono que está unido a
un hidrógeno está unido a un flúor
también está unido a un bromo y está
unido a un cloro
y en estos momentos dejamos de lado
tantito la estéreo química y simplemente
estamos mostrando que este carbono
encuentra unido al hidrógeno al flúor al
bromo y al cloro y realmente hemos
dejado la estéreo química porque como
podemos ver esta estructura de puntos
que acabamos de dibujar podría
representar cualquiera de estas dos
estructuras que teníamos en el caso del
estéreo química que hicimos
anteriormente verdad están todos
conectados de la misma forma tenemos un
carbono directamente conectado a un
hidrógeno a un flúor a un bromo y a un
cloro así que no podemos decir que estos
dos y son - son son y son menos
estructurales el uno del otro tenemos
que decir que son estéreo isómeros que
les difieren en su estructura
tridimensional de sus átomos muy bien es
la parte central de los estéreo isómeros
ahora nuestra siguiente definición son
los enantiómero shockey
estos son los en ante o menos que
esencialmente son este estéreo isómeros
que no se pueden superponer en su imagen
espejo
nuevamente como vimos en el vídeo
anterior este de la derecha que de hecho
podríamos verlo en la imagen esta esta
molécula de la derecha es la imagen
espejo de la de la izquierda y no
podíamos superponer la de la derecha
sobre la izquierda ni al revés verdad
así que por ello son moléculas
diferentes son enantiómero del uno del
otro que por cierto es la palabra griega
para referirnos a opuestos o contrarios
digamos muy bien
finalmente nuestra nuestra última
definición es la de centro que irá muy
bien o que también se le conoce como
centro de calidad o centro de estéreo
génico o muchos términos que podríamos
utilizar aquí y esencialmente es un
carbono tetraedro es decir uno que tiene
hibridación sp3 y que tiene cuatro
grupos distintos así así que cuando nos
fijamos en el carbono que tenemos en
esta digamos estructura de puntos este
es un arreglo de traer y ccoo de sus
átomos es una geometría te trae drica y
tiene cuatro grupos distintos
unidos a este carbono verdad en el caso
en este caso son cuatro distintos átomos
tenemos un hidrógeno en flor un bromo y
un cloro y entonces cada vez que veamos
un carbono tetraedro que tiene cuatro
grupos distintos unidos a él entonces
estamos creando un centro quiral y este
carbono de aquí justamente
un centro quiral y cada vez que
encontremos un centro quiral en realidad
esto significa que tenemos dos posibles
estero y son menos verdad tenemos dos
posibles esteroides o menos y podríamos
escribir una fórmula a que una fórmula
general 2 elevado a la n donde n es el
número de centros quirales el número de
centros quirales nos da el total del
estéreo isómeros posibles que hay verdad
en este caso tenemos solo un centro que
era el entonces eso nos dice que es 2 a
la 1 que son 2 son dos posibles estéreo
y son menos y que es justamente el que
tenemos a la izquierda y el que tenemos
a la derecha
estas dos son moléculas que no se pueden
superponer en sus imágenes espejo son
estéreo y somero si son un tipo especial
de éste horizon - que llamamos en anti o
menos verdad hemos hablado mucho sobre
el número de exterior de este vicio
menos o más bien eso es lo que haremos
en el próximo vídeo en el próximo vídeo
vamos a adentrarnos con mayor detalle en
el tema de los centros quirales y cómo
identificar el número de centros
quirales en una molécula